la chambre de métiers et de l'artisanat
de l'essonne accompagne défend les
entreprises artisanales de notre
département
l'idée originale de notre série est de
glisser un élu du territoire dans la
peau d'un artisan pour une journée afin
qu'ils comprennent mieux son métier et
ses préoccupations découvrons ensemble
notre artisan d'un joueur olivier
léonard je suis président de la
communauté d'agglomération de val d'or
je suis maire de sainte geneviève des
bois et je suis très heureux de pouvoir
participer à l'opération
artisan d'un jour parce que c'est
toujours très intéressant finalement
être au contact de ceux qui font
quotidien de notre société
je m'appelle moustapha sy de gan je suis
gérant la société viendra nous avons
opposé des entreprises artisanales de
l'année dernière avec mon frère et
nous sommes une menuiserie ébénisterie
bonjour monsieur le président est absent
et de gan merci de nous accueillir
moi ce qui m'intéresse en discutant avec
vous c'est que vous me disiez un petit
peu qu'est ce que vous attendez
qu'est ce que vous attendez de ceux qui
sont en situation de bonheur d'or vous
voyez moi j'ai beaucoup d'ambitions j'ai
encore beaucoup de vocations à grandir
et à est encore plus parce que je ne
peux pas cibler tous les secteurs
d'activités qui sont enfin que dans la
menuiserie
il faudrait encore plus de personnel
formé à toutes ses variantes de la
menuiserie et pour ça j'ai encore
beaucoup d'ambitions de l'agrandissement
de locaux plus grands et c'est de plus
de machines mais il faut que tout ça
puisse qui se met bout à bout quoi et
pour ça j'ai besoin aussi de l'aide des
pouvoirs publics une politique en les
charges dans l'effectivité du travail
avant de trouver le bon gars ou mon
poste des fois on est obligé d'y passer
six mois un an
et des fois on n'a pas assez de temps
avec les normales code du travail à
trouver la perle rare
voilà
vous êtes équipé pour bosser on va vous
embauchez des enjeux c'est quand même si
beaucoup la formation est là dessus là
nous on appelle une responsabilité c'est
à dire que on puisse aider à ce que des
jeunes accèdent à des formations
aujourd'hui les métiers du bâtiment en
particulier john va sortir déjà prêt
prééquipés entre guillemets parce qu'on
lui fera toujours un complément de
formation mais prééquipés à utiliser
n'importe quel type de machine
voilà le métier rang
oh là impeccable maintenant on prend un
marteau
allez artisanat la plus grande
entreprise de france je trouve que c'est
un vrai slogan intéressant c'est souvent
cette petite structure on voit que même
si c'est un parent qu'il ya de salariés
supplémentaires que finalement il ya de
l'emploi qui se crée qui de l'emploi
durable ou quoi un premier la pièce
autour de la place et qu'on va pousser
maintenant c'est tatort prénationale
impeccable et sinon votre clientèle
elle est très diverse comment ça
fonctionne je travaille que avec le le
client entre guillemets professionnel
vous avez quand même travailler et vous
continuez à travailler dans des endroits
finalement assez prestigieux rallié tout
à l'heure du stand citroën a au salon de
l'auto et on oublie des fois que il ya
des artisans derrière qui sont les
fleurs qui sont les acteurs
3 puis légèrement pas trop fort et elle
va se mettre en place tout cela va
trouver son chemin
j'ai envie de montrer que je suis
capable de faire de belles choses de le
faire des choses différent de
d'accomplir des choses que des limites
que je hier j'étais pas capable de faire
et tout ça me donne envie de grimper un
peu plus haut tous les jours quoi je
suis content de voir passer cette
journée avec le président de
l'agglomération du val d'orge j'ai pu
exprimer mes craintes mes doutes et
aussi les joies
je pars avec le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu et d'avoir été coupé